what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have even more Fantastic Four
News Today specifically in regards to
the casting of Sue storm today we got
news of who Marvel Studios wants to play
Johnny Storm you can check out the video
we did earlier today on that and
yesterday Mila Kunis acted like she knew
who the members of the Fantastic Four
were going to be stating that she is not
going to be playing Sue storm or be in
the Fantastic Four but she knows who is
maybe she was referring to Mr Fantastic
maybe she was referring to sue storm or
maybe the entire Fantastic Four team as
it seems like Marvel Studios has found
who they want to play each role except
for maybe the thing as of right now he
is the only character that we haven't
heard Marvel Studios has offered to an
actor to play but today we are hearing
from Insider Daniel rpk that Marvel
Studios has offered the role of Sue
storm AKA The Invisible Woman to Margot
Robbie that's right Harley Quinn our new
Barbie coming up Margot Robbie has been
off for the role and I do have to say
she does have the look for Sue's storm
however I want to hear from you all
about this do you think she would make a
good Sue storm in the MCU or would you
just see Harley Quinn I've already seen
a ton of tweets and comments online
stating that she shouldn't be Sue storm
because she is already an iconic
superhero character over at DC so what
are your thoughts on this do you think
that since somebody plays an iconic
character over at Marvel or over at DC
they shouldn't cross over into the other
superhero franchise slash universe I for
one can definitely see how fans might
not want this but I also don't think we
should limit them to just one superhero
franchise because I actually do think
that Margot Robbie could make a very
very good Sue storm in the MCU and I'm
actually picturing Adam Driver who is
apparently going to be playing Reed
Richards next tomorrow Margot Robbie at
Sue storm and I like it I actually think
that they could work really well
together they're both very talented
actors and they both already have
training and acting experience for kind
of superhero franchises already of
course Margot Robbie being Harley Quinn
in many different projects means that
she definitely knows what it's like to
film a superhero type of movie same with
Adam Driver being kylo Ren he has that
experience already experience that
Marvel Studios is probably going to want
not only is this project very very
important to Kevin feige and those over
at Marvel Studios but they know the
people at Marvel know how important this
project is to us the fans so getting
very talented actors to play these roles
would be a pretty smart move if they are
going to go with big name actors for
those roles if they're going to go with
smaller name actors then of course they
just have to make sure they are perfect
for the role but they have to do that
for big name actors too they have to do
that with Margot Robbie with Adam Driver
whoever it is they have to make sure
they are perfect for the rolls however
that goes both ways there is another
side to that and that is does the actor
or actress feel like they are perfect
for the role can they do the role
Justice and that is the question that
Margot Robbie apparently has to ask
herself right now since Marvel Studios
reportedly has offered her the role of
Sue storm now if the people out there
who have offers from Marvel Studios
right now accept the roles then right
now we know who three out of the four
Fantastic Four members are going to be
we know everybody but the thing and we
have some rumors of who the thing could
be but again right now if everybody
accepts their offers this is our current
Fantastic Four lineup Margot Robbie a
sue storm AKA The Invisible Woman she
will be According to some reports
already married to Mr Fantastic in the
movie and they will actually be parents
and her married partner Reed Richards
aka Mr Fantastic will be played by Adam
Driver people had mixed reviews about
this one but this does make sense
because Disney has worked with him a lot
for the Star Wars movies and Beyond Star
Wars he's an incredible actor he has a
lot of range and can do many different
roles and the same thing actually goes
for margarabi she can do extremely
serious roles she can do very funny
roles she can kind of do psychotic rolls
of course thanks to Harley Quinn and
she's really just a very talented
actress all around this is important for
the Fantastic Four because they are a
serious group but they do have a lot of
comedic aspects to the group and in
particular Sue actually needs to be the
one who kind of grounds Reed Richards
like in the comics she keeps his feet on
the ground and Margot Robbie is very
capable of doing that now as far as the
Human Torch is concerned you can check
out my full video on that that I did
earlier today but apparently the role of
the Human Torch has been offered to Paul
muscal he kind of rose to fame thanks to
the miniseries he was in normal people
and what's interesting is that if they
go with Adam Driver Margot Robbie and
Paul muskell the ages are kind of
matching up here it's wildly known that
Sue storm and Reed Richards have a
pretty significant age Gap well Adam
Driver is 39 years old Margot Robbie is
32 years old and Paul muscal is 27 years
old and that all falls in line pretty
well we have a seven year Gap in between
Margot Robbie and Adam Driver which
means that Reed Richards Mr Fantastic
will be kind of a significantly older
age than her but not too much Marvel
even retconned her age in the comics to
make it not too much some people in the
comics kind of freaked out because Sue
was 11 years old when she met Reed for
the first time when he was 21. now a
10-year age Gap really isn't that bad
when you're 31 and 41 but it was kind of
weird when she was 11 meeting Reed for
the first time when he was 21. so they
retconned that eventually so a seven
year Gap is kind of in that sweet spot
Reed is significantly older than her but
not by too much but then of course
Johnny Storm is the younger brother to
sue storm and Paul is five years younger
than Margot Robbie that's actually
perfect so this is the cast so far it
does seem like they're gonna go with a
comic accurate route at least for their
ages now of course just because they're
an age in real life doesn't mean that
they can't say their characters are a
different age this happens all of the
time in movies especially superhero
movies like we know Toby Maguire wasn't
in high school when he was filming
Spider-Man 1 he was 26 years old at the
time and like I said and everybody knows
this happens all the time but we've
gotten a lot of reports stating that
Marvel Studios really does want to be
pretty much comic accurate with the
Fantastic Four and fingers crossed that
this is true and one of the last reports
that we've heard for it the thing is
that Marvel Studios wants a Jewish actor
to play the thing because Ben Grimm in
the comics is Jewish now we haven't
heard that Marvel Studios has offered
the role of Ben Graham aka the thing to
any actor out there right now but two
actors that have been rumored to be
playing the thing or are at least being
considered by Marvel Studios for the
role are Seth Rogen and Jason Segal now
both of them are Jewish and both of them
have actually worked together in several
films we've talked about this before but
both of them can be very very serious
but also both of them are very comedic
as well a majority of the movies that
they've been in are comedies and often
times the thing Ben Grimm is there for
that comedic relief but of course he has
some very serious story lines as well so
this is huge news if these reports are
correct we kind of know who some of our
Fantastic Four members are going to be
if you actors and actresses accept the
roles that were offered to them yes
Marvel Studios might have offered the
role of Sue storm to Margot Robbie but
there is no guarantee that she'll take
it same thing with Paul mascal there's
no guarantee that he'll take the role of
Johnny Storm and as far as Adam Driver
is concerned well we've simply been told
that he is Reed Richards not that
they're still working on it but he is
already going to be him and of course if
we hear anything else about the thing or
the Fantastic Four in general we'll be
sure to do an update so be sure to like
this video subscribe to the channel and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
also don't forget to subscribe and leave
a comment below so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends stuff
or some DC stuff as well we pick a
winner at the end of each month you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf
foreign
[Music]